do you think the slavery in america or
do you think the racism problem
in america is different in that europe
because you're from america i'm not
racist you know i know people are i
don't really
i don't see much racism in america and i
know people i know they're gonna say
that's like because i'm white or
whatever but i'm like you too white to
see it but i just
i don't like where i'm from like
everyone's pretty nice
like i'm from huntley
i have no idea
yeah it's like a it's like a suburb of
chicago right so
because that's the thing i think
sometimes like
black people and
black people in america
a lot of the time in my experience they
see
racism differently from people in europe
they were not in america oh yeah that's
true actually do you know what i mean
yeah it's because of um
well
this is have you ever read this book uh
it's on my show if i haven't read it so
it's it talks about when race relations
are the worst okay
and in the u.s basically uh
the book oh yeah yeah sorry guys um and
it's um thomas so black red next right
white liberals and it talks about like
when ra it when race relations are like
the worst in the us it comes from
um the culture like like black culture
in the us and when i think of i don't
even like saying black culture because
it's really not black culture because it
comes from east england and basically
east england like it was the slave
owners and the annabelle himself
and in the antebellum south like
basically it was a lot of the dialects
like you was you be like like kind of
the dialects that you hear in like rap
culture yeah yeah so that culture um it
was from the slave owners from east
england and it was in the antebellum
cell right and
nine out of every 10 black people back
then had that culture
and one out of every three white people
did and a lot of the yeah yeah so so um
a lot of the
really poor times when the race
relations were really bad it was when a
group of people from the south came to
the north but you can see um
you could see the the um
the like they would they would say the
same things about the white people that
emigrated like the same way they would
describe like black people back then was
the same way they described white people
and that's why you'd see things like
irish need not apply because yeah it was
that culture in the uk they had no
blacks no irish no dogs
oh okay
they're signs yeah
and basically that culture is like
extremely unproductive it's like um they
had
i want to say
67 of the dairy cows
were in the antebellum south but they
only made like eight percent of the
dairy
why because it's just a very
unproductive cult it's like it's i don't
want to say black culture because it's
really not it's like
it's like the rap culture that you see
where it's like an emphasis on religion
but it's like
but it's not really yeah you want to
take like energy they want to thank god
for everything but they're doing all
kinds of crazy stuff
and you would the the number one way
people died in the south was someone
looked at them weird and a sign of
disrespect
and what what yeah what yeah was this
it's
i was just reading this the other day
but um
uh
i don't know but if you if literally
it's like this part of the book right
where it talks about they call it the
so when you say people died what people
that black people did
oh both black white it was it was one
out of ever it was people with the
antebellum south culture that came from
east england right
okay i didn't know that and so the
reason i think that it's like a little
bit different is because like more
people black and white people have that
culture in the us
like that's why i think it's different
because the culture died out mostly in
england
so that's why you think like racism is
different in like europe than it is
america in america i think it is in
america because i think
it's a little bit like worse i would say
in america but i don't really think it's
race as much as that culture i think
people discriminate against that culture
which is like rap culture
all right so do you think because rap
culture is such a big culture now
that
black people
because i know i'm a black man yeah
people have assumed i can rap yeah yeah
i can't rap for [ __ ] right i can brother
you probably write better than me
but it's like because the culture has
been um exported
and it's been seen as a norm yeah
because that's what i made a video
called i'm sick of the black community
right yeah and one of the things that i
said is that
our underbelly
has become our upper echelon
as black people it's like
we don't
glorify
the things that we should be glorifying
we glorify the underbelly so i know that
as a black man someone said to me oh
yeah you must know do you know someone
that sells drugs no
yeah
but you assume so because the culture
has been exported so
cleverly that you think that i'm like
that well
i i find it's different in europe
because
like at nigeria like when i feed people
from like at like africa nigeria they
don't have that culture they really
don't they don't talk about racism
everywhere well you can't well it's a
black continent it's like where's the
racism is that rule black
no i mean like the ones from that i meet
that are like from like that came here
do you know why because well i said my
family from the caribbean right yeah so
our thing is okay so when you're in
africa in your caribbean
your whole thing is if you go to england
or america or wherever
you work your hardest
because you got people back home that
you need to feed right so
black people that come from outside of
america
to the west or to america have a
different mindset
and they say i'm just here to get it
done
get work done do my thing send money
back nigerian americans outpace whites
so do indian americans yeah because
nigerians have a they have a hustle
mentality yeah i'm around a lot of
nigerians but that's that's why i think
it's like not so much race it's that
culture i think people discriminate
against that culture
and like and so in the 60s when race
relations were really bad the race so
the way they would measure race
relations is like one interracial
marriages and two
um
i can't remember the second way but it
was like a seemingly like credible way
and basically race relations were
getting better up until like the 40s and
50s and then the 60s there was a huge
mass of people that came from the south
the antebellum south that came into the
cities right and so then that's when you
started to see like black only white
only areas which i'm not like that's
totally wrong
but i think they were more
discriminating against the culture
because if you look at it you don't
think that you don't think it was a
racing
you think it was a culture thing i think
it was
more of a culture thing than a race
thing because if you look at the one out
of ten white black people that derived
that didn't come from that culture that
were raised up in like the christian
schools in the north
um
they they economic they were
economically outpacing whites
yeah but the thing i would i'm not going
to disagree with you but i think the
thing is is that what it
i think when it comes to racism this is
one of the things i say a lot of the
things that aren't spoken about is the
subconscious mind of people because we
all have biases you can all say that we
have biases right and so we don't know
when biases
are being used or not being used so when
you talk about that like
if you've come from a culture for the
last couple of hundred years that
generally sees black people as slaves
generally
don't you think that bias towards black
people being quote unquote less than
would have influenced them
when it came time for them to come in
well sort of but like half the
population was the north and they were
fighting to free slaves
and then how would you how would that
make sense with like the one out of
every three black people in louisiana
owned slaves
and there was like a lot of people a lot
of them because you export the culture
if you export the culture of
black people or slaves yeah if you
export that psychology
it's gonna turn me just like would you
say that like black people are also
prejudice against like black people of
course okay so okay so you think it's
like the same okay yeah because if you
like i said that's why black people can
come up to me and white people come up
to me and ask me the same question yeah
because the culture has been exported
yeah so cleverly that even black people
think of themselves in this way
and so and so if they're going to think
of if we're going to think of ourselves
in this way
that means
of course general society is going to
think of do you know i mean black people
in a certain way because it's because
the culture
has been exported but i just when you're
talking about general society like it
comes down to individuals and i just
don't see a lot of individuals like
like really heavily discriminating
i don't either yeah like for even me
like i think every person i've hired has
been black
and it's not like i was you know it's
just the people that showed up and
wanted to do the job
and
like i just don't see that that much on
like an individual basis but then that's
the thing i was
asking about europe and america is it
different
because in
because the way in which
i think black americans people in
america
generally tend to think in in my
personal point of view in very victim
yeah backstage but it goes back to like
i think it's the culture i think the
victim's status being a victim is a
culture yeah it was part of the
annabelle himself
it was part of like that culture because
again remember nine out of every ten
black people derived from that culture
in the south one out of every three
white people and there's like an account
in indiana where they're describing like
the whites that came from the south in
indiana it was very similar to the ways
that they would describe the blacks that
came into the cities right okay so
that's why i think i think people
discriminate against the culture
and it's just so happy i think race does
have a factor though sure yeah i think
that's a big yeah i'm not gonna say
because it's like would you prefer to be
next door to
black people who have a certain culture
or black people who don't have a certain